you don't think Bill Gates is
controlling the weather probably you
don't think he's controlling the malaria
I think he's been controlling malaria
but I think he's you know I think he's
you know having affairs with all these
different Ladies as well too these are
these ugly ladies yeah a bunch of bridge
players or whatever bridge players
[Music]
so you guys heard about the Sriracha
shortage I know you knew about that yeah
it's a sad time Sriracha is having such
a shortage that prices for one bottle
have risen up to 120 in the private
seller's market I call conspiracy you
gotta be a fiend
sriracha's like being the diamond
industry right now really yeah yeah but
the diamond industry is like they
control the supply is that what you're
saying oh so it's not a you don't
believe it's a real shortage you think
it's a seriously I feel like they had
the shortage before
like that happened a year a couple years
ago or a year ago right during covert do
you remember that mm-hmm and then they
they go this kind of worked out for us
let's do it again this is eBay right now
so you have oh like a large 60 bucks 55
bucks people are really selling these
things do we have a bottle right here we
do we have like a Kroger fake one that's
the one I got because there was a
certain one yeah like a white label one
wait we have one in the fridge
not a fresh one oh yeah we got the old
one dude I heard people are just
stealing from restaurants too he's
taking monster tables just to like
resell them I guess yeah that was I got
that like
five months ago Dude it is one of the
best hot sauces ever there are some
things I literally can't eat unless it's
Sriracha meat too like Chinese food like
what's the best thing with Sriracha
Chinese food Chinese food
um Thai food Peruvian food thai food hey
sandwiches dude you make some like the
mix of Sriracha mayo you guys have great
great cons yeah dude I can't eat that
[__] without Sriracha you bring it to
the mall they have it oh they have it
okay they have frostbitten meat you
don't like you don't like great cons no
you [__] go and put frostbitten Shabu
meat and you smash it like a butterfly
that meat is frostbitten and it's
delicious I love it dude I love it
that's why they gotta do a steel top
they gotta do a [__] you know they
cook it real firm and they got those
thick yellow noodles I don't even
knows
I love making these people [__] hate
me too because I'm standing there for
like 10 minutes mashing the [__] down
with both Knuckles and [__] trying to
get every every little dime I love gray
cons dead I'm a big fan is Sriracha hot
enough for you because I know you like
no but it's at least good it's like
delicious okay yeah yeah yeah yeah it is
to me look I'm all into the spice right
but it has to have flavor too yeah
what's the most you pay for one bottle
of sriracha dude I'm cheap as [__] I
would I just say [__] you and I had
Tabasco and I'll just use Tabasco on all
this [__] is there a sauce or a food or
anything that if the price did Skyrocket
you would still buy it
scorpion Tabasco sauce that's my
favorite what is that scorpion is like
the hottest one and it's [__] good
it's by Tabasco yeah oh it comes in a
little black bottle and they only sell
them tiny so what's it on the Scoville
scale you know I don't know but it's
very taut and good
and I every time Nikki always busts my
balls because like I filled a whole
cabinet with that [__] because every
time I go to the store I pick up two
because I'm afraid they're gonna
discontinue it oh yeah that's how I feel
about Peter Pan peanut butter that was
good yeah is there a reason why this
time uh why because the first week uh
was because he had a Fallout with his uh
chili grower like they were Partners or
something and then he had to switch
supplier but he's been supplying like
most of his [__] for ages and then I
think after that he went and found some
spots in Mexico it's a shortage of
chilies themselves then that's probably
what it is you know we're like
um you know with our climate [__] like
being different this year because you
know like we're in June and usually it's
hot as [__] at this point right dude
Vegas hasn't hit 100 yet really and it's
been almost a year yeah it's been
awesome so it's been it's been [__]
up the produce
so like wheat even you know everything
they mold after it rains and then it's
not supposed to be like that right now
so a lot of that [__] like the crops are
being [__] up I didn't even know about
that damn
it's it's kind of cold here yeah it was
like 65 when I flew in here yesterday
yeah it's always great too yeah it's
been really overcast recently what do
you think this feels like April honestly
I just think summer gets is getting
pushed back and I feel like every year
it's been getting hotter a little bit
later it's been it's been staying colder
a little bit longer and I just think
that's what's happening you don't think
Bill Gates is controlling the weather
probably you don't think he's
controlling the malaria I think he's
been controlling the malaria but I think
he's you know I think he's you know
having affairs with all these different
Ladies as well too these are these I'll
go ladies yeah a bunch of bridge players
or whatever bridge players that's what I
think I don't know why he looks that way
for the most richest powerful man and
what he used to be the most richest
powerful man in the world like I look
like a [__] I know if you look at Bezos
dude what if what if that is the look
what if that's the look of the most
richest powerful person in the world um
there's doesn't it make sense to be the
thing you are if you got to that point
what are some things that you you would
add to Bill Gates style to make him not
look like such shoulder pads immediately
shoulder pads like you know the Kanye
ones yeah oh yeah he started wearing
football pads look at yoga [__] out
there dude he's like muscle arms he's
under his shirt what's an alternative
haircut he could have well for one I
think he should probably go flat top 90s
flat top yeah you think you got the hair
for it huh I think you should go perm I
think I think he should get a little
steroid thing going I mean have you seen
Robert F Kennedy working out yeah dude
it's insane
yeah definitely looks like he's working
out at Venice Beach
that's what I said
I don't know I can't tell
as a steroid expert I think he's a
[__]
user lover of he's into trt but at his
age I condone it okay so yeah imagine if
Bill Gates had muscles
and then he also dressed like a 1980s
crack dealer from Brooklyn like Run DMC
you know what I mean remember those guys
with the mesh jerseys
mesh Jersey yeah with the little crop
top ones yeah yeah crop top mesh Jersey
fat gold rope with a clock on it or
something bro nothing crazy big there's
like small I like the clock I like the
clock you think we would like them more
after this nobody would say this fool
did kovid like he created covid released
it look how cool he looks no way he did
it you should get the same treatment
then well no one liked fauci even from
the beginning because this isn't the
first time he did this he did this in
the 80s or 90s bro people love fouchy
what are you talking about if this
becomes the new look for white men in
power that would be so funny
a mesh half cut mid-drift yes with flat
top haircut yeah yeah and then also you
kind of see them come in a mile away
like you see another white guy coming up
with the football jersey oh this guy's
trying to be a man in power yep
and every time they do a speech they
have to go on stage and do some New Jack
Swing Dance yeah
[Music]
and then they they start yeah with what
up homies just to just to warm up the
crap that'll be so good see I would
listen to him about vaccine stuff more
see that's why people like Elon and
people like Obama because of pop culture
and this is where people like Bill Gates
just absolutely [__] up because did you
see what he looked like when he was
young when he was like 16 he still
looked like Mr Rogers yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's where he [__] up what who
where dude how can you be 16 or 17 and
wear those cardigans
hey you know what's funny or like those
those sleeveless vests dude Joe's kind
of right though you got it for Christmas
from his aunt you know like people do
that my mom dressed me like a [__]
little businessman for 20 years 20 years
yeah and now look what you're like look
at you yeah yeah he's a successful white
man
exactly in the flesh right here like
when I see Mark Zuckerberg do Jiu Jitsu
a part of me is like I kind of like him
more that's kind of dope I've never I
had no feelings about him and then I see
that he's doing Jitsu and I was like
he's probably a really good guy that's
what I that's what I feel right after
that's where people be [__] up dude
relatability do you think uh Bill Gates
should start doing I think you should he
could probably [__] use some Jujitsu
dude
you know it's kind of scary though why
if he knows well it's hard to
assassinate him now
like he got it's hard already knows he
probably got a whole team he'll come
kill you and kill your whole family you
can't assassinate Jujitsu guys no dude
[__] way
dude would you trust me for medical
information
right yeah hey good good good go get
back and then go get the Boost key get a
couple boosters
foreign